everyone this is Blair from victory I'd
like for advanced diagnostics working on
a 2018 Toyota Camry I'm gonna be adding
a remote I already put the key in the
Flippen this is this was the original
working key I just came from an auction
and we're gonna be putting this remote
in what I like to do is I like to use
the non remote key to turn the car on so
I can have the other one in my hand to
program the remote so we go in this
program remote
okay I'll let me know when I can attempt
let's try it again okay
so press lock/unlock together and we
heard it take okay
just like the old systems it's just the
new body style everything is working
properly so once again it's just like
the type four systems just the flip key
and it works great what's gonna simpler
for victory I like for advanced
diagnostics have a good day